herzlich willkommen bei unserer schönen
luft männerrunde hier vor rita becker
kollege der boss und christoph der
jackpot überhaupt
[Musik]
die lage
ich glaube die frage wie ist die lage
ich glaube der kollege war ich heute mal
wie die lage ist und zwar exakt was
kommt jetzt erklären google
ich habe das mal hier für dich genau
recherchiert wurde diese frage ja seit
jahren schon einmal klein heute in
düsseldorf das sind die koordinaten hier
die ich aufgeschrieben 51 grad 13
minuten nördlicher breite 6 grad 47
minuten östliche breite das ist unsere
jetzige lage
ok also aber auch seine basis in köln
das habe ich ja auch die koordinaten der
lage in köln noch auf recht geben erst
dann hier 50 grad 56 minuten nördlicher
breite und 6 grad ist in 60 minuten
östliche breite dass er die lage
da hab ich mir das auf das kannst du
gerne mit eine sensation er wer hat das
wehr hat das bezeichnet das hat meine
wenigkeit gezeichnet und redaktionell
okay das ist besser als ein autogramm
glaube ich aber jetzt wissen es endlich
geklärt amro ist ihm erklärt ja und bei
euch sie hat eine platte gemacht habe
ich gehört sag mal hat noch platte
natürlich nur bei uns in unserem fall
gold platte wohl ihr persönlicher sicher
ist natürlich immer nur das armen beim
gebet amen in der kirche oder die gräten
meinem fisch aber jetzt in dem fall
denke ich schon dass es ein guter gold
anwärter ist vom inhalt ob die platte
jetzt gold geht das kann ich natürlich
nicht sagen nun auch nicht beeinflussen
da müssen die jungen herrschaften und
die jungen damen da draußen wirklich mal
in die läden stürmen
über itunes über amazon sich die platte
bestellen
versuche von gold zugehen wie das star
wars roboter und das war wirklich mal
versuchen gold zu holen die radler dann
klappt es leute unterstützt uns dabei
unseren wir haben ein spendenkonto
eingerichtet
naja damit endlich beginnt zwei auch mal
auf die eins geht wirklich das
spendenkonto ist bei amazon und bei
itunes genau da kann man einfach
angenommen oder ihr kommt auch zur
vorbeugung auch noch die cd kaufen
da wird ein persönliches spendenkonto
eingerichtet in meiner firma regions
also aber und das finde ich ja schon
jetzt nicht bevor jpg zwei rauskommt
gibt es glaube ich jetzt 15 schon vier
aus wenn ihr das interview führen
es werden fünf wieder herauskommen ja ja
ja sicher christoph du hast ja im
endeffekt 21 tricks wenn der richtige
fan der erotische die 21 tracks und dann
hast du noch nicht mal nach adam riese
da ist ja noch nicht mal ein viertel der
tracks manchmal vorher
und wir haben auch diesmal extra darauf
geachtet nicht unbedingt die härtesten
oder die stärksten tracks alle aus
fackeln sondern viele tracks also meine
persönlichen lieblings tracks vom album
die sind noch auf dem album drauf die
kennt noch keiner das heißt es ist nicht
so dass wir jetzt hier die ganze
munition das ganze pulver vorher
verschossen haben und dann auf einmal
bekommt dann nicht mehr viel sondern es
ist aus meiner sicht eher umgekehrt das
immer geschmackssache aber wir haben auf
jeden fall besser raus gehauen aber auch
ein bisschen was laid back ist
rausgehauen mit du kennst den westen zum
beispiel also ein bisschen versucht so
ein bisschen mix zu machen und die leute
werden glaube ich sehr überrascht sein
wenn sie das album hören
denn es wird sehr hart und auf die
fresse gehen noch einige bretter noch
drauf nach dem ersten album
was waren die gründe es jetzt zu machen
vielleicht nicht früher zu machen und
später zu machen will kam es warum jetzt
drei jahre sind verstrichen drei jahre
sind eine lange zeit können viele kinder
geboren werden sage ich mal
und dementsprechend ist wieder eine neue
generation an müttern herangewachsen die
natürlich auch wieder mit rené trier zu
werden denn das ist das konzept um jbg
es geht nicht um die skills
es geht auch nicht unbedingt nur um das
um den beat selbst auch aber in erster
linie geht es natürlich um das mieter
geschickt werden
jungmann ergänzen und der zu eben nicht
schon sehr gut erklärt ich kann ja jetzt
nicht viel hinzufügen
also prozentual gesehen 30% bizeps 70
prozent dafür sei der dafür zusammen
gezogen oder wie wartende jahren
dazwischen mehr in den jahren dazwischen
hatten wir natürlich immer mal wieder
den einen oder anderen kontakt mit der
ein oder mit der ein oder anderen selben
dame die dann von uns gleichzeitig
sexual penetriert worden ist
zwischenzeitlich hatten wir uns auch den
namen double penetration gegeben anstatt
kollegah und farid bang und wollten
unter diesem synonym rapper aber haben
dann gedacht kommen sind dann wieder auf
unserer alten wurzeln zurück gegangen
weil zu dir zu dem double penetration
zeiten da muss ich auch ehrlich sagen da
wurde nicht nur mit der geschickt
sondern auch die ein oder andere ledige
frau die auch keine kinder mehr hat oder
das heißt keine kinder mehr kinder
ich versuche trotzdem noch mal irgendwie
das auf eine schiene zu bringen ist
jetzt nicht untergeht
wie war das nach wenn man immer mal
wieder kontakt hat aber dann nach
einigen jahren ja wieder so eng nicht
nur zusammenarbeit sondern auch
letztlich befreundet ist und zeit
miteinander verbringt war das neues
gefühl oder habt ihr da weitergemacht wo
er vor drei jahren auf genau so ist war
neues gefühl und zu dem stichwort eng
zusammenarbeiten da wird dir der kollege
jetzt noch einiges zu sagen na ja
eventuell gespannt es eng wurde weit
kann man sagen in den sechs monaten in
dem wir dann wirklich eng
zusammengearbeitet haben
nein aber nun natürlich auch ein
bisschen seriosität und herr interview
zu bringen wir haben uns dann getroffen
und haben dann wir haben dieses läuft
bezogen düsseldorfer hafen wo übrigens
auch in jean schöner wald kommen habe
ich auch viele texte geschrieben immer
aber die nächte durchgemacht und dann
habe ich dann irgendwann sie als die
sonne aufging habe ich mich immer auf
den balkon gesetzt aber so ein schöner
tischen habe ich meine texte geschrieben
weil sonnenaufgang und das war schon
eine schöne sache da war ich noch einmal
da hat er verrät eine gehabt und die ist
mir so eine sache gehen kam die
irgendwann morgens dazu mir vor wie etwa
antennen irgendwie und ich war das schön
aber meine texte am schreiben und dann
wollte sie sich dazu setzen
hallo und soll ich dir frühstück machen
dazwischen ruhe und die worte so small
talk und da ist ein text entstanden gut
da hat sie doch hat sie hat ziemlich
inspiriert habe ich zu ihr gesagt erste
faustregel [ __ ] kein smalltalk für
haus für mich sind frauen nichts anderes
als ein gebrauchsgegenstand bloß objekte
die blondie ventilatoren ich habe bei
doc ist der penetration das handy am ohr
und regel drogenverkäufer oder versucht
zumindest denn das gestöhne der [ __ ]
ohrenbetäubend die bohrgeräusche ich
stelle sie leise mit einem um schon
besser wir hauen auch frauen denn wir
sind für gleichberechtigung der frauen
die mit euch was zu tun haben wollen bei
welchen texten
ja sie können überhaupt nicht
respektieren trotzdem alle mädels kommt
zu unserer tour also frauen die die
natürlich was mit uns zu tun haben
wollen das sind dann natürlich
oberflächliche frauen die nur auf
äußeres achten
weil wenn man nach den charakteren von
uns beide geht sehe ich da jetzt kein
grund für die eine oder andere dame
irgendwie da mit uns zusammen zu finden
also es sei denn sie ist eine frau die
sich gerne vergnügt und auf 20 cm
stoßkraft steht da seid ihr natürlich
herzlich willkommen bei mir da habt ihr
auch mal ein rap hat er wirklich was in
der hose hat und ich spreche nicht jetzt
von beinen sondern schon vom bein aber
auch ein drittes bein oder so
und da wirklich auf tiefgehende
gespräche hoffen da sind sie bei uns
glaube ich nicht ganz an der richtigen
adresse weiter das glaube ich gut auf
den punkt gebracht in allein usa
jahrelang ballerte ich rum mit der ecke
und traf auf den falschen wie [ __ ]
die mich töten
deswegen freunde oder freundinnen
besucht uns trotzdem wie gesagt man kann
ja auch mal vielleicht auf nonverbale
ebene zusammenstoßen okay aber ich sage
dir nur so vor der kamera oder wie
gehabt könnte etwas mit frauen anfang
und dann könnt ihr nichts mit anfangen
könnt ihr nur miteinander reden
was können wir was mit frauen an fangen
ja im gegensatz zu unseren anderen
kollegen
wer zweifel so unseren anderen rapper
kollegen können wir natürlich schon was
mit frauen anfangen
die frage ist berechtigt weil das
natürlich auch keine
selbstverständlichkeit im deutschen rap
ist dass die männer mit frauen was
anfangen können
bei uns ist es auf jeden fall der fall
wir sind in dem fall eine ausnahme und
ich denke schon dass wir mit frauen
einiges anfangen können
oralverkehr analverkehr ja man kann ja
auch noch ihr wisst schon was ich meine
also es gibt viele sachen die und kaufte
alle das alles weitergehen wir nicht
mehr so gut aber dann sind ja da allein
als verfallen feierlich arrangements das
spritzen schön botox man kann sich ja
immer noch so alles mögliche spritzen
umgezogen da ist jede kandidatin nummer
eins und dann kommt wachstumshormone
spritzen mit spritzen mit kaktus der
großen spitzen und da kannst du fix
sensor
wenn du jetzt kommt das aus der rinde
stacks zitate liege bringst oder sind
der sache jetzt allein schießt weil ich
habe mich vorbereitet genauigkeit fragen
der nächste er eine freestyler um die
ecke kommt mit seinem eastpak rucksack
mit jimmy motiven drauf oder astronauten
und der will mich wieder betteln dass
ich da vorbereitet bin ja dass ich mir
meine karriere so in gefahr bringe wie
das einige hätten es geschafft haben ja
gesagt mir schon ganz schön hier steine
in den weg zu legen und mich auf dieser
basis anzugreifen so habe ich versucht
ein bisschen meine freestyle skills zu
verbessern und dass es mir glaube ich
ganz gut gelungen
das heißt du bist sicher wie macht man
das heißt also sein üben wie kriegt man
sehen weil vorher war galt das nicht als
eine seiner stärken
du musst einfach erst mal musst du
musste ich zum beispiel 20 kilo abnehmen
dann habe ich mich schön rucksack
gekauft der kapitalismus schief
aufgesetzt dann wurde rasch weibliche
offiziere östrogene indizien damit die
stimmlage hoch geht und dann ging ich
teilweise echt als absoluter hit peter
schuster vom feinsten so und dann hast
du auch das feeling und ich da rein zu
fühlen und so habe ich meine freestyle
skills trainiert
okay bei dir aus mit dem bei mir ich bin
eher der vielfalt fixierte rapper als
teil nicht aber auf jeden fall weit da
bin ich schon freund zu und da schlage
ich auch gerne mal mit voller wucht
was kommt danach jbg 2 nach utah wir
euch schon mal macht man sich gedanken
bevor man ein abo anfängt was kommt
danach oder ist man so fixiert auf das
was man tut darf man nur noch ich damals
einen tunnelblick darauf hat also wir
sind jetzt gerade jbc jpg 12 also sind
wir schon sehr fixiert wir haben
natürlich sehr viel stress wir haben
natürlich auch sehr viel arbeit aber wie
sage ich immer so schön es macht spaß
das macht laune
erst der a stand keine ahnung was los
hast du wieder hat neues gelernt ja und
dementsprechend schauen wir mal dass wir
hier das ganze über die stränge kriegen
und dann denke ich doch dass ich schon
noch die eine oder andere überraschung
gibt für den ein oder anderen fan da
draußen
man weiß ja dass ich gerade einige an
einigen projekten arbeiten bin aber wird
begeht 2 steht in erster linie vor und
das wird dann auch wirklich wieder
anfangen hier mit dem auto tune schön
und ich hoffe auch auf einige nachfolger
songs von vielleicht der story und
jasmin und ich würde auch ein vielleicht
nur winter herbst frühling und wie
gesagt schön gesangs fuchs und die
punchline dichte reduzieren die panne
und 4
das ist einfach zu viel
das ist ich muss mir jetzt gut und es
ist echt zu viel des guten
danach wieder schön kommerz rap okay
wäre gold gehen ihr werdet die 1er
werdet wahrscheinlich baden gehen auch
hier sollte es nicht kommen jetzt das
ist eigentlich behindert komisch
irgendwie so das ist mir unbegreiflich
es klingt noch asoziale als der erste
teil und deswegen kommerziell ist auf
jeden fall der falsche ausdruck es ist
überhaupt nicht kommerzielles battle rap
es ist ganz harter street rap es ist
kein themen tsonga es ist kein song
irgendwie keinem wort spieler dabei sind
wo es um ein ernstes thema geht außer
bei vier elementen vielleicht da geht es
natürlich schon die hip-hop-kultur namen
kollege und ich das mal aus unserer
sicht betrachtet ja und da der junge
mann auf jeden fall wirklich gute arbeit
geleistet
wir sagen und ich würde sogar so weit
gehen dass ich sage das ist das
unkommerzielle release der letzten 20
jahre
und das geht auf ein neues wissen nicht
dass das wusste man ja nicht wurde er
als wir angefangen haben mit dem album
wir wurden immer das war schon eine
erwartungshaltung da aber du konntest
nicht damit rechnet dass das so durch
die decke geht
deswegen der erste teil wurde indiziert
wir haben trotzdem ein jahr darauf
hingearbeitet haben sehr viel zeit
energie und auch geld darin investiert
mit dem risiko dass es vielleicht nach
einer woche vom markt ist ne und das ist
glaube ich das anti kommerzielle
vorgehen was man überhaupt machen kann
und deswegen sieht man daran ganz klar
hier ging es um den spaß an der sache
und regierung von sprechgesangs müttern
und das ganze drum um dann machen wir
halt nie gesagt wieder ein paar autos
und dann holen wir die kohle wieder rein
wenn der index zuschlägt nach einem
gemeinsamen projekt wie geht es weiter
mit euch werdet ihr noch mal was
gemeinsam machen oder trennen sich die
wege
wenn immer gemeinsam was man ja auf
jeden fall
wir sind nicht wie der rest die sich
streiten vertragen die sich wieder diese
ganzen komischen muss die man immer
sieht in der deutschen szene wir sind
anders wir sind wirklich anders als die
oder ich sehe es genauso also ich denke
schon kollege und ich in der
konstellation wird man uns noch häufiger
sehen und werden wir auch in der
vergangenheit halt immer nach jpg 1 mm
und auch sehr sehr vielen sachen
gefüttert und laufen sind uns halt immer
hier und da mal über den weg gelaufen
und ich denke nach so einem großen
release werden auf jeden fall noch hier
und da gemeinsam die ein oder andere
mutter von dem ein oder anderen
sprechgesangs artisten sexuell
penetrieren er kann man sagen ich bin
gespannt
ja das ganze sein also wir werden auf
jeden fall die leute nicht im stich
lassen
macht euch keine sorgen es gibt
natürlich wird man humor befreite die
ihre sarkasmus nicht verstehen natürlich
werden wir jetzt nicht die [ __ ]
mucke überhaupt machen danach sondern
das geht schon weiter
wir lassen euch nicht hängen freunde ich
meine es gibt genug andere vögel
deutsche website ist ich zitiere mein
freund klose von genetik ein
auffangbecken für sozialfälle und das
richtige vögel rumlaufen um das zu
erkennen so glaube ich kein ornithologe
seien insofern wir werden euch nicht im
stich lasen freunde
werden weiter gas geben vielen dank für
dieses schlusswort gerne
[Musik]